[Música]
este febrero el gobierno de Nicaragua
llevó a cabo acciones para despojar a
más de 300 ciudadanos de su nacionalidad
en una primera ola más de 200 presos
políticos fueron expulsados del país en
rumbo a Estados Unidos pocos días
después se anunció que otras 94 personas
Perdieron su reconocimiento como
nicaragüenses muchos de Los afectados
hicieron en su día parte de la
revolución sandinista del presidente de
Daniel Ortega como la escritora de
giocondavelli que hoy nos acompaña en
directo a América yoconda Gracias y
bienvenida
Gracias a ustedes por estar por
escucharme
yo cuando usted está fuera de Nicaragua
más o menos desde finales de los 90 y me
corrige si me equivoco Cómo interpreta
esta medida en su contra y en contra de
otros expatriados justamente en este
momento en pleno 2023
Bueno yo estaba en Nicaragua Yo he
estado en Nicaragua yo regresé a
Nicaragua en 2011 algo así y estaba
viviendo en Nicaragua ya no tenía ni
casa en otra parte y
interpretó la medida de una manera muy
dolorosa siento que es una ofensa muy
grande a todos los que hemos estado
luchando por Nicaragua por su libertad y
también una idea peregrina de pensar que
nos van a arrancar la nacionalidad
así de un día para el otro con una
maniobra absolutamente ilegal porque no
hay en la Constitución de Nicaragua no
existe la privación de nacionalidad
hicieron una especie de remedo de
corrección de la constitución pero que
no Es legal porque solo se puede cambiar
una constitución en dos legislaturas y
la hicieron cambiar Express o sea todo
es un montaje absolutamente vengativo de
este gobierno Porque todo lo que estamos
en esa lista lo único que hemos hecho es
ser críticos y manifestarnos en contra
de los abusos de Derechos Humanos que ha
hecho Daniel Ortega y Rosario Murillo
bueno Y entonces como califica usted la
situación de Derechos Humanos en su país
con todos los expatriados y expulsados
quien queda para hacer oposición
quedan los nicaragüenses que están ahí
quedamos nosotros o sea yo creo que la
oposición no solamente se hace dentro
del país ya nosotros nos hemos visto en
esta situación antes
cuando la guerra contra somoza cuando
decimos
cuando derrocamos ese régimen desde el
frente sandinista en ese momento
muchos de nosotros estábamos afuera
estábamos exilados igual que ahora
estábamos en situaciones muy difíciles
Mira yo creo que la los pueblos
encuentran su manera de sacudirse las
dictaduras Porque esa es la verdad la
dictaduras
más tarde que más tarde o temprano
siempre caen y creo que la dictadura de
Ortega está muy debilitada está muy
desprestigiada y cada día se
desprestigian más entonces mira yo tengo
mi pasaporte nicaragüense
pero este pasaporte para mí no hace que
yo sea nicaragüense o sea el otro día
hasta lo rompí Porque pienso que que hay
que decirle a la gente
la nacionalidad yo tengo el país mío que
lo Llevo Bajo Mi Piel he sido
nicaragüense y seguiré siendo
nicaragüense hasta el día que muera mis
libros van a decir que soy una poeta
nicaragüense cuando ya estos Tiranos
pasan a la historia de una manera
bastante negativa Yo todavía voy a hacer
poeta nicaragüense
nosotros vemos su gesto de rechazo en
las redes sociales y en los medios que
divulgaron pues este acto de ruptura de
su pasaporte ahora usted hizo parte de
la Revolución que hace 30 años llevó
Ortega al poder y que expulsó Anastasio
somoza usted lo decía hace un momento
porque cree que decayó este ideal por el
que llegó Ortega Cómo llegamos hasta acá
Mira porque así sucede en la historia o
sea nosotros hicimos una lucha heroica
contra la dictadura de somoza luego
tuvimos muchos problemas cuando la
revolución empezó porque los Estados
Unidos inició también una guerra contra
nosotros una lo que se llamó la guerra
de la contra y en todo ese proceso de la
autoritarismo cuando hay una guerra los
autoritarismos se exacerban y Daniel
Ortega apareció creyéndose el gran líder
cuando se termina la revolución
realmente Porque mientras la revolución
estuvo había una dirección colectiva de
nueve personas él no era el el líder de
Nicaragua él jamás fue el líder de
Nicaragua Esa era la lo que aparecía en
los medios pero realmente había una una
dirección colectiva cuando se da en 1990
termina la revolución
sube Violeta Chamorro al poder y Daniel
Ortega y si decide Volver al poder y
hacer cualquier cosa y en esos 30 años
este hombre se ha desnaturalizado ha
hecho pactos
muy negativos con presidentes corruptos
vendió Incluso el derecho al aborto
terapéutico de las mujeres nicaragüenses
para congraciarse con la Iglesia
Católica
a totalmente destruido los ideales de la
Revolución y lo único que tienen de la
Revolución y que usan es
los los colores las banderas que nos han
usurpado a todos los que realmente
hicimos la revolución
yo cuando la palabra escrita y la
palabra hablada son una herramienta
múltiple y usted lo sabe muy bien una
herramienta de desahogo pero también una
herramienta de salvación nos permite ver
además otros mundos que son posibles
cuando estamos en momentos de crisis y
por eso yo le quiero pedir a usted una
amabilidad que además sé que ha hecho en
otras entrevistas con nuestra audiencia
Pero además con los nicaragüenses
quisiera pedirle que declame para
nosotros un poema y así cerrar este
espacio
con mucho gusto mire Este es un poema
que se llama despatriada
no tengo dónde vivir
escogí las palabras
allá quedan mis libros mi casa el jardín
sus colibríes las palmeras enormes las
apodadas bismarck por su aspecto
imponente no tengo dónde vivir escogí
las palabras hablar por los que callan
entender esas rabias que no tienen
remedio Se cerraron las puertas dejé los
muebles blancos la terraza donde bailan
volcanes a lo lejos el lago con su piel
fosforescente la noche afuera y sus
colorines trastocados me fui con las
palabras bajo el brazo ellas son mi
delito mi pecado mi Dios me haría
tragarmelas de nuevo ahí quedan mis
perros macondo y caramelo sus perfiles
tan dulces tu amor desde las patas hasta
el pelo mi cama con el
mosquitero ese lugar donde cerrar los
ojos e imaginar que el mundo cambia
obedece a mis deseos no fue así no fue
así mi futuro en la boca es lo que
quiero decir decir el corazón vomitar el
asco y la ranura que era mi ropa yerta
en el ropero mis zapatos mis paisajes
del día y de la noche el sofá donde
escribo la ventanas me fui con mis
palabras a la calle las abrazo las
escojo soy libre aunque no tenga nada
Muchas gracias muchas gracias a ustedes
yo con David escritora y activista
nicaragüense gracias a usted por su arte
y por sus palabras Gracias
y a nuestros televidentes Les pedimos
que continúen conectados con directo a
América en segundos volvemos con más
[Música]